hi there steve kaufman here
this is the second of my
videos on faqs frequently asked
questions about language learning
uh you'll hear my wife
playing her piano in the background
i hope it doesn't bother anyone i think
it's kind of a nice
background accompaniment
uh i'm still uh
thinking fondly back to my two weeks in
russia i really enjoyed it i found the
people lovely i felt
so much at home there it was wonderful
and i got to practice my russian
now
i often get the question from people
they say
you know i've been studying for six
months a year i can't remember any words
i keep forgetting my characters if
they're learning chinese
i listen but there's still things i
don't understand what should i do
and and there my advice is just take it
easy
it takes
time
and
there's a famous frenchman whose name
escapes me but who is
in china and speaks phenomenal
chinese i wish i could remember his name
um but i've seen him his chinese is
flawless
and he
explained what he did
and he basically studied largely in
france before going to china
did a lot of listening and reading but
he makes the point that like the way he
expresses it if i remember correctly was
we have to know it before we can learn
it or something like that and i have
done a video where i say you have to
learn it before you can study it
you have to let it kind of flow in you
and the main uh one of the main problems
with modern language teaching is
that and
we expect the learner to be able to
somehow
produce the language without mistakes
we expect the learner to remember things
uh we have unrealistic expectations the
learner has unrealistic unrealistic
expectations of him or herself
and the teacher has unrealistic
expectations of the learner or the
system seems to require
that that somehow
the learner can produce the language
it's not going to happen
and if it does happen
it's it's a short-term victory because
anything that's learned for an exam will
quickly be forgotten it takes a long
time
and some things slot in earlier and some
things slot in later and you have to
give your brain a chance to get used to
the language and so you will continue to
forget what you've just learned you will
hear this i listen to things in a
language and the same passage even after
i've read it even after i've looked up
the words and i listen to it and i don't
hear it i can't understand it
that's just the way it is it takes time
so the big thing the big tip in language
learning is take it easy take it easy
if you put in the time
i get back to my three keys of language
learning attitude
time and attentiveness
ata attitude time and attentiveness if
you want to learn the language if you
like the language if you believe you can
learn the language
that's a a attitude
t if you put in the time
and i mentioned my first
video about listening which enables you
to use up all kinds of time for list for
language right so if you put in the time
if you have the attitude you put in the
time and then
try to be a little attentive try to
focus on what you're hearing
try to do things that are going to help
you notice what's happening the language
if you do those things eventually it'll
click in but don't be impatient take it
easy and that's tip number two take it
easy